Lucas is on Instagram Dave I've got
credit cards with high balances I'm
following your steps to pay them off my
question is should I close the accounts
and never look back
once they're paid off let's see Lucas
you have open credit cards that you ran
up to high balances and you pay them off
and you're wondering if you should keep
them sounds like a dumb question of
course you shouldn't keep them what's
the point in paying them off and you
have a tendency use them we've noticed
so of course you pay them off and of
course you close them and of course
you're done with credit cards you're
done with credit credit card you ever
crack a credit card you know I don't
have a credit card
I have debit cards and I go travel more
than a two of you put together and I put
up with the same stuff everybody else
puts up without they're my debit cards
worked just fine thank you very much and
do everything a credit card look except
put you in debt so you have to rethink
this folks you have to rethink it
permanently so get you some debit cards
put some money in your account don't buy
stuff if you don't have money it's kind
of that debit card thing works and you
close all the credit card accounts
all of them every one of them this is
the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]